and here's a case in point as to what
Brady can do in a different system
versus what freedom or lack thereof he
had with the New England Patriots Bruce
Arians has recently said that an
obviously Aryans Brady's new coach in
Tampa Bay aériens has said that Brady
was adamant about adding Rob Gronkowski
now look I'm always viewing these quotes
through that very skeptical eye that I
have as to whether or not there was
tampering going on and whether or not
they were talking to Gronk when they
shouldn't have been and has already been
some flashes to make us think that there
was tampering both as to Brady and as to
Gronk but Arian said that as to the
prospect and the ultimate reality of
adding Rob Gronkowski to the team it was
really Tom Tom brought it up to me and I
didn't even think it was a possibility
that Gronkowski wanted to come back
Brady was adamant about yeah he really
wants to play he'd love to play with us
so GM Jason like got the ball rolling
with the Patriots conversation was there
he's working out he's in great shape
he's raring to go so we're looking
forward to getting on the practice field
and look I I'm trying to picture what it
would be like for Tom Brady to go to
Bill Belichick's office and be adamant
about adding anyone to the team and what
Belichick would say to him he would say
Tom that's that's our that's our area
not yours you play we coach do your job
possibly with the Bill Parcells
expletive included right well yes yes I
mean not like he's gonna listen to the
top I do I mean you know I wouldn't be
shocked if Tom got in his ear last year
a little bit about the Antonio Brown
situation and tried to help Fester that
along a little bit but like to what
you're saying Mike he's not like
Belichick nobody in New England's gonna
be cornered or pressured by Brady or
anybody else I mean you know Mr Krabs's
have a hard time going down there and
tell Bella Jack what to do like that I
mean it's just hey they've they have
crossed every T and dotted every I as
far as across the globe and scouting
players players that might be in players
that are gonna be available in free
agency players that they have you know
looked into their contract situation and
think they might be a post June 1st cut
or some sort of surprise
marie-claude they have done their
diligence in every facet so yeah they're
not gonna be that way but this is
different in Tampa and also they know
with Brady it's a one or two year shot
here where they want to make it work and
Brady's gonna be able to teach them some
things down there where again like we've
talked about a little Mike where when he
gets drunk in the building and shows you
know Tampa some of the schematically New
England was doing all these years and
then some of the schemes they were doing
within it I would be shocked I bet you
Byron Leftwich you're Bruce of the
Arians are gonna sit there and go damn
this is how you guys coach this this is
what you did and that's what's scary
because this offense is creative already
and then when you add a few wrinkles in
like that you go whoa that could be
special I love Bruce Arians but tomorrow
look at this quote hi I'm sorry Bruce
he's making it look like it was all Tom
that talked to rob gronkowski I mean
again this is throwing dirt on the
tampering trail hey we didn't do it we
didn't talk to him
Tom's the one that talked to him we
didn't tell him to talk to us we had no
idea I was amazed I didn't think of me
think there was a possibility of getting
Grogg look the NFL has shown no
inclination to go down that rabbit hole
the NFL does not like to announce to the
world
we've got cheating we've got corruption
we've got tampering we've got rules on
the books that are blatantly violated
but between what Bruce Arians said out
of his mouth at the Scouting Combine
about an intent to call Tom Brady about
this notion that they didn't even talk
to Tom Brady that airings and life
didn't even talk to him until the
Wednesday night a free agency week after
it already had been reported for more
than 24 hours they had a deal with Tom
Brady in place and now this Gronk thing
on top of it the I had my playbook for a
month before I joined the team even
though whose property the Patriots at
the time contractually this just I look
I want to look at this and say wow tom
has a lot more influence in control and
freedom and yet there's also a chance
that this is just a story that was
concocted to keep the Buccaneers out of
trouble Chris do I definitely yes I mean
I don't think there's any doubt about
that but I think I believe Bruce I mean
you know one I don't know if Bruce has
it in the
that good of a liar you know that's like
he said what he said to us at the
combine and whatever it is anything you
hear about Bruce Arians I mean he says
it how it is and I would think that you
know Brady did bring this to the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers that he kind of did
bridge that gap and then where it went
from there I don't know I don't know
Brady gives him the playbook or if Tampa
goes oh he's interested hey here's a
playbook you know or what's his address
we'll send it to him or here Tom you
take it and you give it to him whatever
it may be but I do think Brady's the guy
just stoked the conversation right he
was joking you're not getting the
playbook oh yeah yeah sure sure punch
line yeah sure sure why should people
book Rob
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports